hey guys I recently had a question from
several people that wanted to know how
many grams of protein do I need to
consume in my diet if I'm on a ketogenic
and in a manifesting program okay
apparently when I told them the ounces
that wasn't good enough they want to
know in grams so before I get into that
let me just kind of explain something if
there's glucose or sugar in the diet the
body will always go for that first and
that's why we want to keep the carbs low
between 20 and 50 grams or less okay so
if we keep the carbs low then the body
will then burn muscle protein unless
you're eating enough protein okay so we
want to have a moderate amount of
protein because if we don't have enough
protein our body will start using your
own muscle even before the fat so we
need certain amounts of protein so I'm
telling people you need between three
and six ounces now what does it come out
to well at the very minimum you need
point three six grams 2.7 grams per your
body weight in pounds now I'm not giving
you the kilograms you can do the
conversions talking about pounds okay so
I'm 180 pounds okay so it multiply 0.33
and I get roughly about 65 it might be
sixty four point eight or something like
that okay so that's how many grams of
protein I need for the whole day okay
minimally so 0.7 times 180 equals 126
grams of protein for the whole day okay
now that's if I'm doing like three meals
so if I divide this by three each meal
would be on the low end it'd be about 21
grams per meal of protein if I'm going
in the high end let's see I'm an athlete
I'm younger a lot of physical activity
I'll need a little more protein I'm
stressed I need more protein so we
divide this by three it comes out to 42
grams anything more than this though is
going to be a problem on the liver and
kidney it can actually strain the
kidneys in the liver and it could create
kidney stones and it can also create
more fat on your body because it's gonna
convert to sugar so we need some but we
don't need too much so this is the range
right here if you wanted to know now
when calculating this there's a lot of
confusion because people go online and
they look up let's say you're gonna look
up beef right the nutritional facts for
beef four ounces is 113 grams so right
there you're gonna go back to here it's
gonna be like wait a second 113 grams
for 4 ounces that doesn't make sense but
realize when you look this up you're not
going to use total grams for the beef
because that beef is made up of
different things we want the protein
grams not the total grams so for beef
for 4 ounces we have about 26 grams we
have about 8 grams of fat and the rest
water like 80 grams of water will make
up the total of 113 and collagen and
some other things okay so we're really
going to only use the protein so that's
what that's what we're talking about and
if you're looking at fish chicken lamb
eggs they're all gonna vary in the
amount of protein per unit of volume
okay or weight so don't worry I'll have
a calculator I'm almost done with this
macro calculator for you so you can go
in there and punch new numbers and it
does all the calculations for you you
know then you don't have to worry about
anything so I'm working on that in fact
I was working then all day today from
five o'clock in the morning until I'm
here which is about five o'clock okay so
let's say we get our protein in
correctly and we're doing great on that
and then you do in a minute fasting so
now you're going to go to two meals and
then one meal well you're not going to
need the quantity quantity of protein is
going to go down down down because your
body's going to recycle protein and
you're going to not need the quantity of
protein because the body is stimulating
growth hormone that's one thing and
that's going to cause a protection of
your muscle protein from
being broken down all right so now if
you handle this you're not going to lose
any muscle so the body will then have no
choice but to burn its fat reserve okay
and when it burns the fat you can have
ketones now in the beginning you're
gonna have to consume more fat as if
you're insulin resistant they're also
going to be really really hungry it's
going to be really hard to go from one
meal to the next however when you start
becoming adapted the need for fat will
go down because the goal is to get your
bodies to start eating your own stored
fat not necessarily just to rely on the
dietary fat okay so in this case maybe
in the beginning you're adding keto
bombs and you're adding extra fat and
this and that bulletproof coffee but
then as you get into it maybe you won't
need that maybe you could just get the
fat from the protein that you consume I
just found for example I bought from us
wellness meets online I found hamburger
that is fifty five percent that's forty
five percent fat incredible I've never
seen anything like it so I ordered a
bunch of it and so that's what I'm going
to consume tonight so you would need to
add any more fat that's enough fat of
course a lot of it will be you know
baked off when I cook it but the point
is that if you just focus on the fat in
the whole food you probably won't need
to add very much unless you're trying to
maintain your weight in which case you
want to add more fat so that way your
body will maintain and maybe you can
gain a little bit of weight okay all
right thanks for watching
hi guys thanks so much for watching
press this little button down here and
says subscribe and I will make sure that
I won't send more than five to ten
videos a day okay no I'm just kidding
it'll be one or two thanks